Hello everybody and welcome back. It is
yet another horrible day in Chicago with
40°ree weather in May. Fortunately, I've
loaded up on so I'm good to stay in all
day and do absolutely nothing. Anyways,
let's make some systems design videos.
I'm going to get out the iPad and we can
get started by talking about leaderless
replication. All right, so let's get
back into it. I've got leaderless
replication up on the iPad and let's
talk about it. So for starters,
basically the gist is if you recall
leader list replication is when you have
one guy on the left over here. He can
write to multiple database nodes. So as
you can see he's writing to two of them.
I got this guy over here and this guy
over here. And then a different reader
can read from any arbitrary number of
database nodes. So in that case he's
going to read from this guy again and
also the one on the top. When he does a
read such as that, he might notice that
this guy on the top was not written to.
So what he can actually do is perform a
read repair in order to update it with
proper data and also in addition to that
just over time uh you know kind of as
time flies the databases will actually
communicate amongst themselves in order
to pass information and make sure that
reads aren't too stale that is known as
anti-entropy. As you can see we've got a
Merkel tree located over here to
indicate how these databases actually
compare their state and to see the
discrepancies between them. So, we've
gone ahead and done our kind of review.
Let's move on to the new content for
today. So, the new content that we're
going to be talking about is quorums.
So, I teased last time that basically
there's a way that you can write in a
leader list replication schema and then
somebody else is actually going to
instantly be able to read that instead
of having to rely on read repair and a
bunch of anti- entropy in order to
propagate those changes around. So, what
is a quorum read and a quorum write?
Well, let's start out with a
hypothetical situation. In this case,
there are nodes in the cluster. So,
let's call this variable n equal to
five. And uh that's you can see there
are basically five database nodes. Okay.
So, our writer on the left over here is
going to perform writes to three of
them. So, as you can see, we've got a
right here, a right here, and a right
here. And let's call that number of
nodes that we have to write to W. In
this case, W is basically saying, okay,
as a client, once I get three
confirmations from database nodes that
they've received my right, I will
consider my write successful. Okay, so
it's basically just waiting on three
successful writes to be like, okay, I'm
good. My right is in the system.
Similarly, we've got another guy over
here on the right side of the screen. He
wants to read from R nodes. So, let's
say that R is equal to three, right?
He's going to try to read from three
different database nodes. So, let's say
he picks these two as the first, right?
Oh, no. That's not very good because
they don't have the updated value. How
is he going to see the guy on the left's
updated value? Well, now he has to pick
one more node. And all three nodes that
he has to choose from have already been
written to. So, in this case, regardless
of which one he actually picks, you
know, he's going to be reading from at
least one node with the most updated
value that was just written by the guy
on the left. So, why does this actually
work? or rather when does this actually
work? We recall that n is the number of
nodes in the cluster. W is the number of
nodes that we'll write to and r is the
number of nodes that we'll read from.
When w + r is greater than n, we have
what's known as a quorum read and a
quorum write. In that quorum read and
quorum write, we know that the two sets
of nodes that are both written to and
read from will have at least one node in
overlap. Why? Because of this phrase
right here. It's simple math. Because of
the fact that W plus R is greater than
N, there needs to be at least one node
overlapping between W and R. Hence, we
can always see the most update date
value at least once and we'll have a
correct read. But let's move onwards.
So the question now and you might have
been thinking this is hey wait a second
with quorum writes didn't we just
achieve strong consistency and to remind
you all what strong consistency is it
basically means that everyone who's
reading from our database pretty much
any node or any type of read is going to
return the most up-to-date value
everyone's going to agree on what that
value is right so regardless of which
nodes I read from as long as I have a
quorum of nodes that I'm reading from
aka at least our successful reads, then
I should in theory see the most
up-to-date value in our database. So, is
this actually the case here? And it
turns out that even though it seems that
way at first, it's actually not. So, I'm
going to give a few examples of where
kind of quorum writes as potentially
strongly consistent databases fall
apart. So, the first one is actually
going to be a race condition. Imagine
we've got three databases and at the
same time three people writing. So the
first guy is going to write to the first
database and actually all three people
are going to write to all three
databases. But due to the rate condition
that is present when you send out a
bunch of writes, those rights are going
to come in in a different order. So you
can see that you know we've got version
one over here. These are the earliest
rights to arrive at the database. And
then version three, these are the latest
rights to arrive at the database. And so
what ends up happening is due to this
race condition, all three databases
actually disagree on which write has the
latest version number. And that's a
problem. Why? Because now if I'm a guy
over here and I'm trying to read from
these three databases, right? Let's
imagine that I have to choose two of
them. Let's say we use two and two as
our quorum. So the number of nodes that
we have to read to guarantee that we
have a quorum read is two. This guy is
going to choose from database 2 and
database 3. And so all he knows now is
that W1 or W2 is the answer. And that's
not even conclusive. But if I were
another guy over here and I also did a
quorum read to database 1 and database
2, I would have a completely different
result. And so even though these two
guys are reading at the same exact time,
they are not getting the same answer.
And that is obviously a problem. In
fact, the database isn't even conclusive
because a majority of the nodes don't
agree on what the value is. So obviously
leaderless replication even with quorum
rights is still prone to write
conflicts.
Let's move onwards to another case which
is actually just going to be when writes
fail. So let's say again we have a three
node setup. So in this case n is equal
to 3, w is equal to 2 and r is equal to
2. So 2 + 2 is greater than 3. So that's
how we know we have a successful quorum.
So this guy on the left is going to now
write to two nodes. He attempts to write
two nodes and one of them succeeds over
here on the top and the other is going
to fail. So let's say beforehand all
three databases in the cluster agreed
that this value x was equal to 6 and
this guy over here was trying to write
that x is equal to 10 and he succeeds on
just one node. Now the problem is that
when this guy over here on our right
tries to read, not only does he see the
fact that x equals 10, even though this
write technically wasn't valid, why was
the right not valid? because it didn't
successfully get to two nodes. It only
got to one node, but it never got
overturned. So, that's a big problem.
And the reason this is a problem is
because this guy here thinks that the
value is x= 10. But if I have another
guy over here, and he reads from these
bottom two nodes, he is going to think
the value is x= 6. So, it's possible for
two people who are reading from our
cluster to actually disagree on the
value. Hence, our quorums are not
strongly consistent. If there were a way
somehow for us to roll back this right
and say okay well it didn't succeed
everywhere so x clearly is not equal to
10 then of course we would be strongly
consistent but that problem and ability
to be able to roll back is of course not
guaranteed. It would require this guy
sending another network request to the
top database node which is not
guaranteed to get there. It could fail
too. And then one final case that is
worth mentioning is something known as
sloppy quorums. So the gist of sloppy
quorums is that often times people have
different database clusters, right? So
for example, if you have one in America
for your North American users and then
you have one in APAC for Asian and
Australian users. Basically the gist
here is that you know sometimes one
cluster in a geographical region can
just go down for a variety of reasons.
So you can see that's happened with
cluster one. And now as a result what a
smart system might do that's actually
resilient is they start routing a rights
from an American user to the APAC
cluster. And so these are still actually
going to be quorum rights because as you
can see n is equal to three
and w is going to be equal to two. So
we're still writing to two nodes and
those are going through successfully.
But let's say all of a sudden that
cluster one actually comes back up. You
know someone plugs the data center back
in. Everything's good to go. And now
this guy reads from cluster one because
that's where his rights are actually
being sent. So these are reads right
here. He is not going to see the rights
that he made before because they're in
cluster 2. And so that is kind of the
concept of a sloppy quorum. And the gist
here is that for this situation to kind
of fix itself, what we need to do is
actually take the data from cluster 2
and transfer it back over to cluster
one. That is known as a hinted handoff.
And so if we perform that now we're in
good shape again. But again it's not
strongly consistent simply due to the
fact that I can just read that left
quorum after I make quorum rights and
now we're still not good to go. Okay. So
basically in conclusion quorums are
really useful right the majority of the
time they are actually going to result
in behavior that kind of resembles
strong consistency. However strong
consistency is not truly strong
consistency unless there are no edge
cases. Unless you know with 100%
certainty and like mathematical
guarantees pretty much that if you're
reading data at the same time as someone
else, you're both going to agree on the
value that you're getting. So basically
leaderless setups can be really really
good for kind of these let's say
relatively chill client side
applications. Something like a social
media app where it's not the end of the
world if some data gets lost. However,
if we're really talking about protected
data that it's super sensitive and you
know if it goes missing, we're in a lot
of trouble, then maybe quorums aren't
the best thing for you. If everyone
needs to be able to agree on what the
current value of the data is, then
leaderless replication setups probably
are not the move. In fact, single liter
nor multiler setups are the move either
for us to really discuss what the right
thing is there. We're going to have to
wait a few more videos, but it's going
to take distributed consensus. So guys,
I hope you enjoyed this video. I am now
going to wait out the cold in my room
alone. And have a good night.